ok die haben wir drin jetzt in den ohren
und ich bin gespannt
deswegen ein hippes lied hey was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
airports video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich freue mich
sehr auf dieses video waren kam es
verzehrt video haben wir gemacht
wir haben ja dieses airport case gold
gefärbt oder wir haben es versucht vor
jetzt kommt es noch ganz gut aussehen
oder warum machst du denn da können
meine finger von karsten wiegands ich
glaube dir gar nichts abbekommen nein
doch es ist aber das letzte airport oder
airportpark video wie man es auch mal
möchte kann etwas über zwei wochen würde
ich sagen vor zweieinhalb wochen sagen
wir mal und ich war wieder unterwegs
dass sie sich auch auf eure ideen
eingegangen und habe zwei weitere
modelle bestellt und zwar haben wir
einmal die wifis 200 tws die wir heute
testen und wir haben noch die 1000 tws
die wohl aktuell so wurde mir das von
euch gesagt als bester airport fake der
zweiten generation gelten lassen mal
kurz hinsetzen erstmal das waren jetzt
ganz schön viele infos auf einmal ist
hier eigentlich gar nicht von mir
gewohnt ich bin ja auch kein technik
kanal
ich mache einfach unterhaltung so ein
bisschen und wir schauen uns nicht um an
ich sage ich habe einen lauf die
soundqualität ist und ob es sich lohnt
für euch diese zu bestellen anstalt für
das original und euro auszugeben
habe ich grade ganz schnell geräte
weiter so weiter so auf jeden fall der
airport stapel nimmt zu moment ich mache
hier auf burg
ja okay so 04 05 kommt aber noch dazu
hier haben wir noch die original die
brauchen wir auch um noch mal eben rein
zu kommen
wir haben hier einmal die originalen
airports für 180 euro
dann habe ich bereits getestet die
sogenannten flirt ports für 55 euro oder
circa 50 euro
und dann habe ich davor getestet.de 12
für 16 euro
dann bin ich noch mehr stimmt ich habe
irgendwann mal welche von milch getestet
die habe ich leider gar nicht mehr aber
die sind an die leute die jetzt sagen ja
ich dachte verlost die diese flair pozzi
wir dir dann hatten habe ich auch
verlost oder instagram also ich hab die
verpackung allerdings behalten um und
die beschreibung auch um halt weiter
testen zu können dass man ihr eure
serien zeigen jetzt nicht mehr existent
bevor wir uns mit den 1000 beschäftigen
beschäftigen wir uns mit den e 200 die
habe ich für 24 euro gekauft auf der
plattform die es kann aber auch sein
dass es die auf amazon gibt habe ich gar
nicht nachgeschaut falls ja frage ich
euch einen link in die beschreibung oder
also uns von babys und ja die haben 24
euro kostet die 1000 tws haben
ich meine 35 euro kostet also an sich
absolut in ordnung wenn leistung hinter
steckt ich würde sagen wir machen die
einfach mal auf da warten ja eigentlich
alle drauf bin
[Musik]
kennst du das wenn du so über seinen
fingernägeln schildmann okay manchmal so
sind die aus ich mache mir einmal auch
wieder zu und dann sagt ihr
das ist schon mal nicht schlecht so
weißt du weil bei den anderen hatten wir
ja oft das problem man hat das so
aufgemacht und wieder zu und es hat sich
halt richtig richtig billig angefühlt so
das ist jetzt hier auch nicht perfekt
aber es ist am nächsten am original wir
können das ja einmal hier kurz
vergleichen ja mal das original hier ist
der fake siehst du das licht ist halt
wieder draußen das grüne licht vorne
naja also ein bisschen was ist natürlich
anders keine ahnung warum wir jetzt
genau diese grünen haben und so sieht es
von hinten aus also man erkennt schon
unterschiede auf jeden fall hier mal zum
beispiel den knopf in der mitte bei den
originalen haben wir den knopf unten und
aber das sind dann so kleinigkeiten
na gut ich habe im internet ein video
gesehen da hat auch jemand diese e200
ausgepackt und da stand hier sogar
airports drauf und hier war auch ein
apple logo drauf das ist jetzt hier
leider nicht warum das so ist weiß ich
nicht aber gut schauen wir uns war eben
die beschreibung anfall sich da
irgendwas verstehen können
das heißt wir müssten eigentlich sogar
weil es konnte man die laden mit support
wireless charging was ja schon mal einig
nächstes wird den preis ansonsten stehen
hier noch unbewusst sie glaube ich ein
bisschen interessanter sind hier was
version 5.0
top in time gesprächszeit zwei bis drei
stunden aufladezeit 40 minuten
ich würde mal sagen kommt jetzt nicht an
die originalen dran die kunden sind
schon lange
also wenn man damit telefoniert oder
sogar musik hat bestimmt fast einen tag
oder wenn ich so also keine ahnung
hatten berlin heraus selten laden also
bestimmt 56 stunden mindestens na ja gut
dann würde ich sagen versuchen wir die
gleiche direkt von zu connecten checkt
auf jeden fall gerne diese videos ab
falls ihr da noch infos zu diesen
geräten haben wollte ich kann ja mal
kurz zusammenfassen
wir hatten hier bei den i 12 die haben
halt 15 jahre und kostet waren absolut
in ordnung ca 15 euro
diese hierfür 50 euro die potsdamer
nicht ganz happy mit die haben uns nicht
überzeugt für den preis seit und die
normalen airports ging nichts zu sagen
die sind meist ja wenn ich weiss das
original kummer man merkt nicht mal
welches fake ist ja jetzt möglichst bald
wieder okay wir mal die kleinen
kopfhörer aus hier vielleicht auch mal
eben die original schauma man erkennt
man daran unterschied hier das ist halt
in einer anderen ist ein bisschen dicker
geschrieben als er vor gericht er ist
jetzt schwer zu sagen es bliebe gleich
schauen aber von der länge vielleicht
die sind oder die ohrmuschel sieht
anders aus wenn ich das richtig sehe
dies ein bisschen dicker na ja dieses
bisschen dicker hier die ohrmuscheln
hast du recht gut erkannt würde ich
sagen das wichtigste ist ja immer der
sound test wer mit der kamera wie juni
dj kennt sich auch mit sound fx und die
sag mal irgendwie sowas was ich leider
etwas für keine airports hast du keine
airports hinaus absolut schlau daumen
nach oben für diesen platz dann versuche
ich dir jetzt mal mit meinem mobilen
geräten zu connecten dazu drücken wir
ganz einfach hier hinten auf den knopf
und warten dann auf andere geräte wie
jetzt jederzeit entscheiden sollten oder
wir öffnen es einfach hier oben und dann
sollte man gleich die aktie kommt das
ging doch schnell zurück man auch auf
die taste und kollekten uns bitte
verbinden und man hat hier sogar direkt
diese anzeige ist das ging viel
schneller als bei den anderen zwei
sprechen original bei denen von den
protesten
dass das stimmt und ich weiß garnicht
hatten wir bei den flyers hatten wir da
auch diese anzeige
ich glaube nicht und haben wir das jetzt
zum ersten mal das war revolutionär dass
meine jetzt nicht verstanden ich glaube
nicht ich glaube ja ok jetzt ist
verbindungen wieder weg aber jetzt bin
ich wieder connected also das ist immer
für mich wie wenn du so eine
klassenarbeit früher wiederbekommen das
weißt du so ist das vom viele läufer ist
ja dass man so gespannt ist okay die
haben wir drin jetzt in den ohren und
ich bin gespannt was irgendein hippies
lied bei winsen meiner
[Musik]
hier reicht also ich muss sagen ist
jetzt nicht perfekt aber ich fand es
eigentlich also bis jetzt das beste von
allen also der beste weg ist klingt in
absolut akzeptabel also würde ich jetzt
persönlich mir selber wollte ich will
jetzt auch mehr hören jurijs rad an rad
der kamera also leute ich muss wirklich
schon sagen bis jetzt ich bin da hast du
also von den 24 eur oder ca 23 erwarte
dass er konnte für den kreis echt okay
aber tiefe und so willst du sagen es
besser als die japanerin die war scheiße
die waren schlecht handel und hast du
dir hier aufgehört wie kann ich also bis
jetzt meiner meinung nach das beste das
okay ich bin ultra gespannt auf die 1000
tws weil das wohl die besten sein soll
ich bin gespannt auf die songs ob die so
ein bisschen an meine jan die originalen
dann kommt es natürlich schwer aber das
video gibt's auf demnächst leute
ansonsten will ich sagen
die werden jetzt auch beim minister fall
muss wie immer konnte auf jeden fall
alex er sich da antwortet einfach auf
meine story dass du dir gern haben wollt
dann wird irgendjemand ausgewählt und
dem schreibe ich dann eine pn your door
sticker wollen natürlich die mailadresse
dann stehe ich euch gezwungen weil ich
persönlich man will ich mit so viel
erfolg kann nichts mit anfangen ein paar
reicht jetzt kommt der krankenwagen
passend zum ende dieses videos ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr wieder da gibt's neues
video haut rein und instagram abonniert
habe ich schon gesagt blogger aktivieren
perfekt